[Music]  general style's chicken is a staple in  american chinese restaurants but the  most popular chinese dish in the u.s is  virtually unknown in china  so what happened  [Music]  [Music]  with  it all started after the chinese civil  war when most of the chinese leadership  fled to taiwan the leadership took this  guy with them the late pong chang kwei  he was after all the chef to the then  acting chinese president on one fateful  day there were a bunch of foreign  dignitaries in town  [Music]  [Music]  the dish was a major hit in taiwan so he  brought it to the united states and  opened up a restaurant  word got out about pong's restaurant  mainly because the then secretary of  state henry kissinger was absolutely  bonkers for general souz  as  you know and love probably isn't the  real mccoy don't let that stop you from  gobbling up that sweet and spicy gooey  and crunchy mess  [Music]  you